lombardi a is a company that supplies
aircraft and trains worldwide we have
the largest supplier of passenger rail
cars in the world
I've always had a motivation to move
people in cities we make cities alive we
make them war and the vitality is the
train system the company was originated
in the 1940s with the ski-doo the
snowmobile vehicle we expanded into
transportation in the early 1970s with
major contracts in Montreal Canada and
also to New York City in 1982 for 825
subway cars so at the start of our
process we start with the sheet steel
like this and this sheet steel comes
from a supplier in the u.s. our first
operation we're going to weld this
together once we completed the car body
we come over here where we put windows
and doors into the vehicle we're now
going to go down through the assembly
line we are going to install the
electrical harnesses the floors the
interior lining so that's walls and
ceilings lighting those will all be
installed through these stations
Bombardier chooses to operate in the
United States because it's one of the
most important markets in the world
it has great growth in emerging commuter
rail regional rail and light rail
systems there is a Buy America
requirement which requires 60% of a
vehicle to have u.s. content and also to
be assembled within the United States we
are the main manufacturer for the US
market we have a lot of customers in New
York and we have suppliers in this area
too
at president we're building cars for New
York City we're building cars for
Chicago for San Francisco for various
commuter systems Florida sunray
check one check one and we're going to
move forward on our test track right now
we're testing Chicago cars we test 13
different systems we're the finishing
end of completing the cars Plattsburgh
station one and off we go